one of the things I think we
ought to look at is I don't know if
there's this has been done but several
years down the line you go and speak to
those people and see how they feel about
what happened yeah and then you kind of
break it down from there at the very
least we probably would want to know how
many people receive treatment that they
shouldn't have received that seems to me
quite a priority here yeah that'll be
good to know wouldn't it I would think
so but we don't know and why not
well I think there are several reasons
we don't know so one is
if we keep it focused on on
jids
I I think they haven't wanted to find
out they haven't found out I mean
their own documents their own
information that they've released under
Freedom of Information shows that there
was a time when they said yes we are
going to record both those who change
their minds prior to medication and
those who do once they've started either
the blocker or hormones and for a couple
of years 2017-18 they said yep we're
doing that and then they said suddenly
said no we're not going to do that it's
really time consuming so they never
collected that data
only they will know why because that
seems quite important data to have
because you
in order to benefit
it it's why I find the argument that
some people make that we shouldn't talk
about you know that talk of D transition
so people have gone through a medical
transition or surgical transition and
then revert back to their natal sex
that doesn't undermine the experience of
those
for whom a medical transition might work
actually I've spoken to you know there's
a there's a trans researcher in Canada
who's doing loads of research on
detransition and he says
we can make treatment better for
everybody if we understand those for
whom it doesn't work as well that's
equally important
because everybody wants to prevent that
happening
so yeah but we've had no follow-up of
jid's patients so we don't know where
they are we don't know
who's happy who's unhappy who's
medically transitioned who hasn't
and it would be equally helpful to know
of those who never transitioned
what was it for them that
that worked or didn't work I mean these
are all really important questions which
we have no answers to
one of the people I spoke to with the
book Dr Juliet singer so she's a child
adolescent psychiatrist she also
happened to be a governor at the
Tavistock
and she felt she was constantly asking
for data as soon as she arrived
and
she felt and certainly others feel that
it wasn't just that it wasn't a priority
which is strange in a clinical service
but it wasn't just that it wasn't she
she felt that they didn't want to find
out and that might be the case only they
will know for sure
um
but she also made the point that if you
don't have the data if you don't know
your patient population you don't know
how many are Autistic or
or gay or
you know have anxiety depression if you
don't know that you don't know the
long-term outcomes of the treatment you
don't know how many people are satisfied
or unsatisfied by the treatment how can
you be experts because what are you
experts in
now those are questions posed by people
who work at the trust
and just finishing off with these d
transitioners
their bodies have been irreversibly
changed
what are they experiencing what what in
what physical state are they left in now
as a result of these puberty blockers
the surgeries the hormones
do we know
I think different people are in
different situations so
a young
I mean your body from puberty blockers
that's not you're not going to be
permanently altered but what I would say
is that I'm still in touch with them a
young still identifies as trans a young
trans man he's 20 now so he was on
blockers for four years between the ages
of 12 and 16.
and he's chosen not to take testosterone
but
still identifies as male now
he broke four bones while on the blocker
and the talk that it's physically
completely reversible well do we know
that because so few people come off the
blocker that we don't really know and
when he came off the blocker no one from
either uclh or the Tavistock ever
followed up on him so he came off at 16.
it wasn't until 18. two years later that
he got his periods
and even now another two years later
they're not regular
he feels left behind I suppose
cognitively and emotionally from his
peers is that to do with the blocker
well we don't know there's no there are
no studies there's no follow-up
so we don't know in terms of d-trans d
transitioners
I think people handle it in different
ways I mean Harriet who I spoke to for
the book
um when I caught up with her again
recently after it was published she's
actually doing really well which is
great and she's much happier
um
you know she lives
with
her voice being a lot lower and
obviously sounding masculine and she's
had a double mastectomy but
um but I think there are also I think
talk of D transition actually masks lots
of things as well because
there are what does it mean like there
are people who've fully surgically
transitioned who've had what people in
the trans Community would call you know
both Top surgery and bottom surgery they
fully surgically transitioned now
and and some and I can't put any numbers
on it some are really unhappy like
desperately unhappy and given the chance
again they would not have done this can
they do Transition absolutely not
because
what would that look like your the body
has been totally changed by
hormones if you've had a hysterectomy
and your female you're gonna have to you
know you're gonna have to take some kind
of hormone all the time and if you
furtherly surgically transition it
doesn't matter how you feel in and of
yourself Society will never perceive you
as your birth sex again that's just a
that's just a sad reality so in a way
detransition it
it's all a bit more complicated isn't it
how do you measure it
foreign